a ferias ahora después de sólo 100 días
puedo informar a la nación que eeuu está
de nuevo en movimiento de nuevo berlín
para marcar sus primeros 100 días de
gobierno el presidente joe biden se
dirigió al congreso junto a él y por
primera vez en la historia de eeuu
dos mujeres ocuparon las dos sillas del
podio la vicepresidenta kamala harris y
la presidenta de la cámara de
representantes nancy pelosi baiden
destacó el éxito de su plan de
vacunación y llamó a los escépticos a
aplicarse la inyección bailén destacó
también su gestión económica de la
pandemia y prometió un plan familiar
para lo que subirá impuestos para
quienes ganen más de 400 mil dólares y
que la economía creó más de un millón
300 mil nuevos puestos de trabajo en 100
días 3
más puestos de trabajo en los primeros
100 días que cualquier presidente haya
registrado en el plan contempla
garantizar la salud y la educación como
un derecho y no como un privilegio el
presidente estadounidense instó además
al congreso a aprobar sus reformas
migratorias a la policía y por un mayor
control de armas tenemos que unirnos
para reconstruir la confianza entre las
fuerzas del orden y las personas a las
que sirven para erradicar el racismo
sistémico en nuestro sistema de justicia
penal y promulgar una reforma judicial
en nombre de georg floyd que ya fue
aprobada por la cámara en cuanto a la
política internacional destacó el
compromiso de eeuu contra el cambio
climático y destacó el fin de la
presencia de las tropas del país en
afganistán antes de terminar mencionó a
rusia su rival geopolítico y le avisó
que habrá consecuencias ante cualquier
escalada de las tensiones y a china- le
dijo que no busque la confrontación
aunque mantendrá las tropas en la región
indo pacífica